mission on va se quitter avec avec
allain leprest avec un deuxième extrait
de votre album donne moi de mes
nouvelles
quand je veux quand je vous aurais dit
que la peine de mort n'a toujours pas
été aboli aux états unis et qu'au 1er
septembre 2005 il y avait dans les
prisons françaises 56 1595 détenus pour
seulement 51 1129 place merci anne
brochet merci à vos bernardo carvalho
merci à vous messieurs merci madame
on se quitte en musique et on écoute une
valse pour hier
tu vas le sera pour rien mon vieux la
belle que tu sers dans tes yeux ce n'est
pas de l'amour c'est une envie d'amour
qui valse avec les nombres prend d'amour
pour deux guitaristes la solitude et
salons pis
et le bal terminé le jour fera tomber
n'est belle que tu tombes et le froid de
la senim la dame on retient fera mal
s'était fiancé de la nuit rabal c'est
normal si pour rien
aum rien
une valse voir ja
ou je
c'est pour rien que tu vas sera
qui tient du vide dans tes bras
la chaleur que puissance et ça nous
dotons sont tous valse dans ta veste
y a pas d'amour yoko ono reste tout ça
se passe dans ta tête
cendrillon à laisser au fond d'un
cendrier la cendre de ses gestes
et nous voici déjà
un bon chien autre ton coeur dans son
étui passé toute une nuit ou deux balles
ce mourir ou rien
une valse pour rien
bon
là
thual sera en rien mon vieux nabeel que
tu sers dans tes yeux ce n'est pas de
l'amour c'est une envie d'amour qui va
ce avec une ombre eux
avec nathalie miravette au piano